[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Google I/O.
Today, we have three things to
talk to you about-- momentum,
mobile, and more.
This year we did
something new.
We had over 110 cities have
viewing parties set up and
stream this event live.
We have activated over 100
million Android devices and
200,000 applications
available.
I'm happy to announce the next
major Android release--
ice cream sandwich.
Users can rent movies from
Android Market and instantly
stream them to their
Android devices.
Today we're introducing
music beta by Google.
You can listen on the web or
any compatible device.
It's just like a
big toy store.
I'm like in heaven right now.
They just gave 5,000
tablets away.
And we get one of them.
Where's yours?
Everyone's so excited about all
these new technologies,
meeting all the vendors.
It's really a great
experience.
Robots are cool, that's
all I gotta say.
And there's lots and lots
of robots around here.
We are here to talk about
the Open Web, the
amazing platform it is.
The pace at which it's
making progress.
We have more than doubled Chrome
users in the last year.
We are bringing Angry Birds to
the biggest platform out
there, the web.
We want to make sure every
I/O attendee gets a free
Chromebook.
[APPLAUSE]
We've been blown away.
Thank you.
Thank you, Google.
All of my friends, they
should really be here.
Who's playing?
Jane's Addiction.
Really?
That's awesome.
That is awesome.
That is the most amazing
platform in our lifetime.
The future of the web, that's
what you make of it.
Google I/O is awesome.
If you can ever get a chance to
go, you definitely should.